New Claude free updates are insane.
Claude just dropped updates that are
going to change how you run your
business. And the best part, it's all
free. Memory, connectors,
scheduled tasks, all on the free plan.
This isn't a small update. This is
Claude becoming your full-time AI
employee. And I'm going to show you
exactly how to use every single one of
these features to grow your business
faster. Let's go. Right, let's talk
about what just dropped. Claude just
rolled out a massive update to their
free plan. And when I say massive, there
are three big things here. Memory,
connectors, and schedule tasks in
co-work. I'm going to break down each
one, and I'm going to show you exactly
how to use them for your business. Real
examples, practical stuff, not theory.
Let's start with the one that changes
everything. Memory is now on the free
plan. Here's what that means. Before
this update, Claude forgot everything
after every chat. Every time you started
a new conversation, you had to reexlain
who you are, what your business does,
what tone you want, what your goals are.
It was like hiring a new assistant every
single day. Now Claude remembers, you
tell it once, it keeps that info, right?
Every future conversation picks up where
you left off. Hey, if we haven't met
already, I'm the digital avatar of
Julian Goldie, CEO of SEO agency Goldie
Agency. Whilst he's helping clients get
more leads and customers, I'm here to
help you get the latest AI updates.
Julian Goldie reads every comment, so
make sure you comment below. Think about
what that means for running a business.
Say you're growing an AI automation
community, like the AI profit boardroom.
You tell Claude once, "Here's what the
community is about. Here's the tone we
use. Here's our target customer. Here's
what makes us different from everyone
else." From that point on, every piece
of content, every email, every strategy
session, Claude already knows the full
picture. You don't start from zero every
time. That's not a small thing. That's
hours back in your week. And now you can
import and export your saved memories
whenever you want. So if you switch
devices, move between tools, or want to
back up your memory bank, you can full
control. If you want to know how to
build full AI automation systems for
your business, not just one tool, but
the whole process, the SOPs, the
templates, the workflows, the stuff that
actually saves you hundreds of hours.
That's exactly what we do inside the AI
profit boardroom. It's the best place to
scale your business, get more customers,
and use AI automation the right way. We
show you real systems, real examples,
and you get access to a community of
people already doing it. Link is in the
comment and description. Go check it
out. Now, let's here's a practical
example of how to use this for the AI
profit boardroom. You'd set a memory
like this. I run the AI profit
boardroom, an AI automation community
that helps businesses save time and get
more customers using AI. Our audience is
business owners and entrepreneurs. Our
tone is direct, no fluff, and always
practical. Our main offer is our AI
automation community. Always write
content that speaks to people who want
to use AI to grow their business. Now,
every single time you open Claude, it
already knows all of that. You just
start working. No setup, no repeating
yourself. No wasted time. This one
feature alone is worth paying attention
to and it's free. Now, there's something
else I want to flag before we go deeper
because this is important. Connectors
are now on the free plan and this is
where it gets really interesting.
Connectors let you link Claude directly
to the tools you already use and there
are over 150 of them. So, instead of
copying and pasting between apps, Claude
can now pull from your tools and push to
them too. It becomes part of your
workflow instead of sitting on the side
of it. Let me give you a real example of
how this works for growing the AI profit
boardroom. Say you want to grow your
community membership. You've got your
audience data in one place, your email
tool in another, your content in
another. Normally, you jump between all
of them and stitch it together yourself.
With connectors, you can hook Claude
into those tools and say something like,
"Look at our last 30 days of signup
data. Find the traffic sources driving
the most new members to the AI profit
boardroom. write me three new social
posts targeting more people like them
and draft an email sequence to convert
the leads who haven't joined yet. That's
not a fantasy. That's what this looks
like when you use connectors properly.
And now it's free. The key thing to
understand here is that connectors turn
Claude from a chat tool into an
operating system for your business.
You're not just asking questions
anymore. You're connecting it to the
infrastructure you already have. Go to
Claude settings, look for the connectors
section, and start with one or two that
make the most sense for your workflow.
Don't try to connect everything at once.
Pick the ones that save you the most
time first. Connect your data source,
connect your content tool, and start
letting Claude do the heavy lifting
between them. Now, the third update, and
this one is the one I'm most excited
about for business owners. Scheduled
tasks in Co-work. This is brand new.
Claude can now complete recurring tasks
at specific times automatically. Not
when you remember to ask, not when you
open the app, at the time you set every
time. Here's what that means in
practice. So you can set a morning brief
every morning. Claude pulls together
what you need to know before you start
your day. New signups to the community,
top performing content from yesterday,
any new questions or activity in your
group delivered to you before you even
sit down at your desk. You can set
weekly spreadsheet updates. Every week
Claude compiles your key numbers,
updates your tracker, and has it ready
for you without you touching it. You can
set Friday team presentations. End of
every week. Claude pulls the week's
data, formats it into a summary, and has
it ready to share with your team. Think
about what you spend time on every week
that is the same task repeated. A
check-in, a report, a content review, a
performance summary. Every one of those
can now be scheduled and automated. For
the AI profit boardroom, this is a
gamecher. You can set a daily automated
task like this. Every morning at 8:00
a.m., pull the previous day's new member
count, top three most active posts in
the community, and any new questions
that haven't been answered yet. Write a
short brief I can read in 2 minutes to
start my day. That brief gets generated
every single morning. You wake up, it's
there, or a weekly one. Every Friday at
5:00 p.m., summarize this week's
community growth, highlight the top
three pieces of content that got the
most engagement, and give me three ideas
for next week's content based on what
members are asking about most. That's a
Friday report that used to take 30 to 45
minutes. Now, it's done before you
finish your last meeting. This is the
shift that's happening right now with
AI. It's not just about what AI can do
when you ask it to. It's about what it
does without you having to ask at all.
The businesses that figure this out
first are going to move faster than
everyone else. Let me pull this all
together. Memory means Claude knows your
business every session. No repeating
yourself. Connectors mean Claude works
inside your existing tools, not beside
them, inside them. Scheduled tasks mean
Claude runs your recurring work
automatically on a schedule without you
having to trigger it. These three things
together are not just updates. They're
the building blocks of an AI powered
business operation. and all of it is now
on the free plan. The barrier to using
AI at this level has basically just
disappeared. The question is whether
you're going to use it or whether you're
going to keep doing things the slow way.
Look, AI is not slowing down. It's
speeding up. Every few weeks there's a
new update, new feature, a new way to do
more with less. The businesses winning
right now are the ones who keep
learning, keep testing, and keep
building systems around these tools.
memory, connectors, and schedule tasks
on the free plan is not just a nice
update. It's Claude telling you that
there is no excuse left to not use AI in
your business. The tools are here. They
are free. The only thing left is for you
to start. So, go set your first memory,
connect your first tool, schedule your
first task, start small, build from
there, and watch how fast things change
when AI is working for you around the
clock. Now, if you want to take this
even further and you are serious about
using AI to grow your business and get
more customers, join the AI profit
boardroom. It is the best community to
learn how to use clawed memory and tools
like it to automate your workflows,
build systems, and scale faster with AI.
If you want to know exactly how to set
up Clawude memory for your specific
business and get step-by-step processes,
that is where you need to be. And if you
want the full process, SLPs, and over a
100 AI use cases like this one, join the
AI success lab. Links in the comments
and description. You will get all the
video notes from there, plus access to
our community of 45,000 members who are
crushing it with AI. The link is in the
comments and description.